people don't get the amount of volume
that it takes to be successful I had a
mentor when I was starting my gyms he
was like we do Flyers that's how we get
customers and so we put out 300 flyers
and I waited and then the next day I got
a call I was really excited as soon as I
picked up the phone he says you uh
dinged my Mercedes and I just
immediately panicked and hung up the
phone but that was the only call I got
from my 300 flyers and so I called the
mentor back I was like hey you told me
this was gonna work he was like how many
did you put out I mean I put out 300 in
total and he just started laughing he's
like hard to know if anything works with
300 he's like we test with 5 000. he was
saying 5 000 and then he said he would
go to 5 000 per day after that meaning
that in 30 days he put out a hundred and
fifty thousand flyers in that same 30
days I put out 300